bonjour jean françois cibien merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous en direct par
téléphone se met tant dans la matinale
de rtl france on va parler de dossiers
médecin qui constitue la pierre
angulaire des soins de la recherche et
de l'enseignement une grande étude sur
leur carrière et révélé aujourd'hui
est-ce que la situation est critique
pour ces filières d'excellence
bonjour merci de nous accueillir
effectivement il ya une grande criticité
la france a été un pays à la pointe de
la médecine dans le monde grâce à ses
universités à ces chercheurs est donc
assez maintien mais ces praticiens
hospitaliers
mais depuis une trentaine d'années le
système est en train de décliner en
parallèle du délitement de l'hôpital
tout simplement par rapport à un nom
d'homme hospitalier qui est sous-évaluée
de plusieurs dizaines de milliards
d'euros par an depuis au moins une
vingtaine d'années ce manque de
financement aujourd'hui en train des
conséquences déplorables en termes
d'attractivité mais surtout en termes de
de compétences même si les compétences
sont là mais vous le voyez en manque de
soignants manque de praticiens que ce
soit dans les hôpitaux généraux les
hôpitaux universitaires alors le rapport
de le ségur de la santé du gouvernement
avait pris en compte c'est les
spécificités de cette profession qu'est
ce qu'il faut en retenir aujourd'hui
c'est pas suffisant les mesures qui ont
été prises
alors nous parler de mesures figure
j'espère qu'un jour nous aurons une
commission dans le kent par enquête
parlementaire
vous verrez que ce soit n'a été que des
mesurettes
effectivement il ya des sommes
conséquentes qui ont été engagées mais
il y avait un tel retard juste un
exemple 30 % de perte du pouvoir d'achat
des praticiens hospitaliers sur 15 ans
ça choque personne différentiel entre le
public et le privé qui de 2 est passé à
trois ça choque personne toute la
permanence des soins c'est-à-dire la
continuité des soins qui est assuré
quasi note quasiment exclusivement par
l'hôpital public et qui n'a pas été
revalorisé depuis depuis 17 ans au bout
d'un moment on peut pas prendre toute la
pénibilité
tout ce que tous les cas les plus
complexes derrière avoir les moyens
suffisants pour remplir nos missions
c'est un problème musiciens qui est
apparu bien avant la crise ducobu de 19
ça s'est amplifié avec la crise center
alors vous avez raison on à l'épidémie
de coville qui est venu à rêver les
landais me comme je vous ai expliqué du
délitement hospitalier un manque de lits
croissant tout simplement parce qu'on
est parti sur une gestion à l'activité
on est là dans l'hôpital usine sur un
problème sur une gestion avec un
principe de rentabilité
est passé pas l'ascension de l'hôpital
public l'hôpital public certes on doit
rendre des comptes à la nation mais on
ne peut pas réfléchir en comptant
uniquement d'activité de rentabilité et
c'est là où il ya là une erreur système
va falloir corriger vite et d'ailleurs
on espère que tous les candidats à la
présidence de la république pour le
prochain quinquennat à venir prendre on
me la santé à coeur la santé de leurs
concitoyens car si personne
ne prendre ce dossier à sa juste valeur
certes on continuera à parler du pouvoir
d'achat mais votre pouvoir de vivre vous
journalistes tous les concitoyens qui
nous écoutent
pour bien vivre il faut bien être et si
on n'a plus les moyens de vous soigner
ça risque d'être beaucoup plus compliqué
pour vous même si on comprend que le
pouvoir d'achat est une priorité de nos
concitoyens également alors 139
démission depuis 2010 huit de ces
praticiens hospitaliers des disciplines
qui ne sont plus représentés aujourd'hui
dans certains chu
alors vous avez tout à fait raison on a
l'exemple du chu de la réunion ou
l'urologie a été balayée
l'urologie donc un service de pointe a
été balayée suite à un rapport igas avec
de grosses histoires de soufa une
bascule vers le privé des choses qui se
passent qui sont très très étrange après
effectivement quand vous avez des
services de pointe
la cardiologie pédiatrique que vous
perdez des habilitations il ya des
choses qui interroge mais regardez ce
qui s'est passé sur la le vaccin le
vaccin il a été découvert par deux
français quand on parle de recherche
sauf que derrière on n'a plus les moyens
de mettre en production tout simplement
parce qu'on n'a pas eu d'anticipation il
ya plus de planification dans ce pays
d'accord à partir de cela il va falloir
qu'on en prenne les bonnes décisions
mais a pu aller vers les solutions on
est toujours aujourd'hui dans réaction
vous vous dites 439 praticiens qui ont
démissionné mais combien de praticiens
universitaire manque-t-il il en manque
des milliers sinna man i milliers pour
en obtenir et justement les jeunes se
précipitent guerre pour venir dans ces
filières
bon l'attractivité ferme au niveau des
jeunes praticiens apprécié c'est
compliqué mais je vais vous expliquer en
en deux mots si vous voulez le les
salaires de nos collègues universitaires
sont pour moitié versée par l'université
pour moitié par l'hôpital ils ont un
temps d'enseignement de recherche et ils
ont également un temps clinique dit
hospitalier leur retraite ne m'intègre
pas le versement
de leurs émoluments hospitalier
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont des retraites
mais qui sont miséreuse misérables et à
partir de là on demande aux jeunes
aujourd'hui de venir travailler 80 90
heures senteurs 110 heures par semaine
avec des salaires qui sont pas à la
hauteur de ce qu'ils devraient être mis
en plus derrière à la différence des
praticiens hospitaliers comme une fan
comme que nous sommes pour la plupart
ils n'ont pas la même retraite que nous
on avait demandé pendant le ségur qu'il
y ait une réunification des statuts et
que chaque statut apporte le meilleur en
termes d' avantages sociaux aux autres
jeux véranda d'une idée de faire
autrement on a fait du saupoudrage on a
divisé les statuts c'est bien dommage
pour faire très court aujourd'hui c'est
un appel à en faire une priorité chez
les candidats finalement
si aucun candidat
ne prendre place
la réalité de la situation aujourd'hui
le système de santé tant de scènes
s'écrouler parce que l'hôpital public
vous le voyez ça on n'a pas besoin de
vous le dire le nombre de lits fermés
des services fermées par manque de
soignants la perte aussi de des valeurs
et là la désaffection de l'hôpital
public seulement aujourd'hui 20% des
internes veulent venir travailler à
l'hôpital
si personne ne prend ce dossier en
compte je pense que ça va être compliqué
pour mes concitoyens dans les années à
venir qu'on partira sur un système privé
qui d'ailleurs a commencé à être mis en
place dans certaines
dans certaines régions merci beaucoup
jean françois cibien de nous avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur arte france